Welcome back everyone happy comic con week this
is going to be my new marvel deleted scene video
featuring a bunch of surprise characters you never
expected in a bunch of easter eggs so if you're
brand new to the channel comic con is happening
this week there's going to be a bunch of marvel
trailers and footage dropping like the black
panther 2 trailer the what if season 2 trailer
footage for the x-men revival series even some
of that new spider-man series that they're doing
of course i'll do videos for everything so
be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
the big marvel deleted scene features a bunch of
characters like there's a ton of stuff going on
in this scene but the biggest ones are actually
president loki of all people in the blue marvel
adam brashear along with marvel inhumans and some
thor love and thunderstuff from the end of that
movie with eternity i believe all these scenes
would have been happening during the earlier ms
marvel episodes because they show her without
her costume like she's just hanging out playing
video games and things got really crazy towards
the middle of that series she probably wouldn't
have been doing that in the later episodes i'll
start with the loki easter egg first but what's
going on is that this is a version of president
loki that we saw in the loki series in ms marvel's
living room while she's playing her playstation
that is a playstation controller so you can guess
which video game she's playing because there's
so much weird multiverse easter egg stuff going
on in here you could theorize she's playing a
version of spiderman ps4 or the miles morales game
that would really twist your brain in a knot to
try and figure out how that could possibly work
but president loki is enough all by himself to
break your brain just to figure out how he could
possibly be here on this world in the 616 main
marvel universe like how does this world even
know about president loki if the tva pruned him
because this is a funko pop of president loki
like we saw during the loki series it's got the
same crown the same jacket everything meaning that
they have president loki merch in this main 616
mcu universe or at least they did in this deleted
scene i think the fact that this is meant to be a
deleted scene shows you that they had some crazier
ideas about how they might treat the multiverse
in this version the timeline before they actually
released the episodes just because of when it was
coming out in the marvel phase 4 order like we're
in the middle of this big secret wars multiverse
saga and things are starting to collide with each
other universes are starting to overlap we're
starting to see way more easter eggs from other
universes show up president loki as far as we know
was a version of loki who created a nexus event
when he ran for president of the united states and
won if that wasn't clear he won that was the big
nexus event just loki being on earth running
for president doesn't cause a nexus event the
fact that he won is what really broke the timeline
his story in the mcu was based on this comic book
version so the tva wound up pruning his timeline
sending him to the void planet that we saw in
the loki series where they dumped everything that
they pruned that's why all the other versions of
loki were there even the ones that were vastly
different that didn't actually look like tom
hiddleston they weren't killing the things that
they pruned that was the big twist that they
were just relegating then to this place trapped
outside the sacred timeline where eliath lived and
would periodically just consume everything that
showed up there cleaning it up so to speak acting
like a glorified trash compactor for kang just
eating all of time and space that weren't part of
his idea of the sacred timeline like he literally
eats timelines so the tva pruned president loki's
timeline how could the main 616 version of ms
marvel buy merch based on him becoming president
of the united states it's just a really cool
really weird idea just the fact that she owns that
might be enough to cause a nexus event there's
figures of most of the core avengers characters
here in their classic costumes which isn't that
surprising it's more of her just being an avengers
fan girl buying a ton of avengers merch and having
it all over her house but right next to president
loki here she has a guardians of the galaxy nova
corps ship and the crazy thing about that is that
the people of earth never actually saw the nova
corps they weren't at the final battle in avengers
end game just the guardians of the galaxy core
characters themselves and they didn't even have
their ship with them the benetar the nova corps
were all killed off by thanos before the beginning
of avengers infinity war in a big deleted scene
which i've already done a bunch of videos about
when he went to zandar to get the power stone from
them they basically just cut out that part of the
movie that's why when he shows up on thor's ship
he already has the power stone right now marvel is
actually working on a nova series for the nova
character for disney plus that will eventually
cover some of that backstory but at no point did a
nova corps ship ever publicly fight near earth in
a way that would make it popular enough in a pop
culture sense for people to create merch based on
it that ms marvel could buy like where did this
come from the big blue marvel easter egg which
is actually pretty cool is in the background here
too she's got an action figure with blue marvel in
a version of his classic comic book suit this is
what he actually looks like in the newer version
of the suit if you remember back to one division
last year everybody thought that adam beshear blue
marvel might be the engineer they kept mentioning
that was going to show up like this big engineer
character he's going to be this really cool
easter egg because most of the biggest stories
he's been in recently were with the captain marvel
character in the ultimate so it makes sense that
he'd appear in a captain marvel related story
like one division with monica rambo's storyline
most of his recent stories also involve monica
rambo because she's also part of the ultimates the
current belief right now is that they'll introduce
a version of him or tease him in some way during
the marvels movie but i haven't heard anything
specific about them doing mcu blue marvel yet
the character is super op like blue marvel's
basic power so that he can absorb and give
off anti-matter like he can give off blast kind
of the same way that captain marvel can do but
with anti-matter he can rearrange matter on the
atomic level he can fly he's super strong like
strong enough to face characters like the hulk
in hyperion even though we haven't got hyperion
in the mcu yet his origin story has a lot of
connections with the fantastic four because he
was trapped in an accident involving the negative
zone that mutated his body kind of the same way
that monica rambo got her powers when she was
mutated by passing through the hex multiple times
they literally told her during that series that
your dna is being mutated at the molecular level
i think it's a little easier to explain how
a version of adam beshear has already existed
on the dl in the background of the mcu movies
so far working for sword or another military
agency like in the 616 universe up to this point
but it's harder to explain where full-blown blue
marvel became a pop culture icon big enough to
warrant them creating merch based on his character
it's kind of like the president loki thing
and the guardians of the galaxy novacore ship
thing like where did these come from the big
black bolt inhumans easter egg here if you look
in the background zoom enhance the background on
the shelves here she's got a figure a black bolt
holding someone up by the neck getting ready to
use his ability to destroy them with his voice
notice you can see him wearing his classic
costume with the exposed part of his mask
we saw a version of ants and mount come back as
the 838 universe version of black bolt and doctor
strange 2 r.i.p so they have canonized the version
of the inhumans to the marvel cinematic multiverse
but so far inhumans haven't appeared inside the
main 616 mcu universe at least as far as we know
there could be ones in the background that
we just haven't learned about yet in the ms
marvel finale they canonized her as a mutant
instead of being an inhuman like they changed
her origin story i've already explained why they
did that the biggest reason is because they're
doing mutants related stuff during captain
marvel 2 the marvels movie and they wanted
her backstory her powers to flow with the story
during captain marvel 2 but also the people who
created the kamala khan character in the comics
said that they actually always wanted to create
her as a mutant but the marvel people that were
in charge of the comics at the time particularly
ike perlmutter forced them to make her an
inhuman instead of making her a mutant character
so actually she was never meant to be an inhuman
that was just sort of like this legal behind the
scenes drama that went on when they originally
introduced the character back in 2013 2014
the big easter egg here for the ending of thor
love and thunder is actually for the singularity
character and what happens to gore's daughter
after eternity recreates her using its power when
he brings her back she looks kind of like eternity
the singularity character in the comics that's why
a lot of people were asking about the singularity
character after the movie came out she looks just
like singularity the easter egg here is that the
shirt that she's wearing is for ms marvel number
35 singularity was a big part of that story this
isn't absolutely confirmed that gore's daughter
love is a version of singularity now because
singularity is more like the living consciousness
of an actual singularity in spacetime and gore's
daughter is meant to be more like the original
version of the character with a few god level
power upgrades bestowed by eternity like she
got powers as a side effect of being recreated
by eternity it's not like it turned her into
this full-blown consciousness of an actual
singularity there's a bunch of other easter
eggs and references here in the background of this
deleted scene but most of it is like really common
stuff like a version of captain marvel shaking
hands with the president more captain marvel
posters there's an iron man mark 3 figure if you
zoom in enhancing the background here though some
of these are kind of blurry so it's a little
hard to make out but this white figure here
in the background almost looks like a version
of emma frost of the x-men that would be crazy
they did just canonize her as a mutant in the
mcu we're gonna see more mutant characters in
the next couple of years in other marvel movies
but you can let me know who you think that this
character is supposed to be it's another one
of those crazy multiverse breaking easter eggs
like where did this come from where did she learn
about emma frost there's a star wars droid behind
her here they've mentioned star wars a bunch
of times in marvel movies so we already know
the star wars is canon to the mcu it seems like
the other characters next to it here on the left
are some dora melange wakandan warriors guardian
warriors all mixed together that would have all
been in the final battle of avengers end game so
that explains why the people around earth would
know about them and be creating merch based on
their characters you can also let me know who
you think this other caped figure is next division
because it doesn't look like a version of thor it
might be just like a second version of vision but
the capes look just a little bit different don't
look exactly like the capes that vision wore one
of them almost looks like the version of vision
from one division where he was dressed like the
original comic book version but it was meant to
be more of a halloween costume version of vision
there aren't that many capes inside the mcu so
you can let me know who you think these characters
are but because this scene is specifically meant
to be an easter egg heavy scene like references
to a bunch of different things all over the place
you can let me know if you spotted any of the
ones that i didn't talk about during the video
i tried to just focus on the big head-turning ones
like blue marvel president loki singularity thor
love and thunder where'd all this stuff come
from where did she learn about all this stuff
who's even selling merch based on characters that
got pruned by the tva that shouldn't be existing
in this timeline like i said it's comic con week
there's going to be a bunch of big marvel panels
a bunch of footage dropping trailers for some of
the stuff some of the other stuff they might not
release but i'll do videos for as many things as
possible it's supposed to start with the what if
season 2 trailer marvel zombies the x-men revival
series so i'll do a video for that tomorrow or as
many videos for footage that they've released and
then after that will be the big black panther 2
panel and maybe some big announcements about the
marvel movies there'll be some big dc trailers
too like the black adam trailer make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel so
you don't miss any of that stuff i'll just keep
doing videos for everything until i get through
all of it there's going to be a lot of really
cool stuff happening speaking of loki here's
my loki season 2 first look video and you can
click here for my black panther 2 dr doom video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!